[Music]
[Applause]
George and Amal Clooney stunned on the
red carpet at the LA premiere of
George's latest film suburbicon I could
have you killed in no time I could kill
you - this is a big night for you first
off you have a mom and her mom you've
got the mother-in-law mother-in-law here
so you guys say nice things okay
babysitting tonight you got to spread
the knucklehead out the Clooney's have a
lot to celebrate these days illustrious
careers and plenty of milestones at
Homewood they're nearly five month old
twins Ella and Alexander here's what
George told et on Saturday at the
suburbicon junket
this is really truly the bathe the
largest step in fatherhood for me at
this point okay
three days ago my children started on
what we would call solid food well what
they went in fine I don't know how it
goes in as a carrot and it comes out the
way it comes out but it was shocking it
was it was shocking what's changed and I
think it may never go back I think it's
gonna be that way forever now and it was
terrifying do you have any baby hacks
like things you can share with your fans
that you've learned that are good tips
don't feed them solid food IV until
they're like 20 do you have nicknames
for them yet now I do after the carrot
incident we're still getting used to
names you know we're still getting used
to having human beings and in our life
too little human beings that we overs
it's pretty funny and it's wild
[Music]